autoafirmación como un país fuerte incluso
así que no captures solo destruye el nuestro
él estará bien con el país
vernos tan fuertes como somos
podemos simplemente llevarlo allí y destruirlo allí
un par de pueblos en pocos minutos
[música]
Soy voluntario desde el año 14
en el frente, usé los drones del dueño
pausa entre el año 15 y
En el año 22, no se llenó si
nuestra tierra esta llena de descanso
muy bonito y para rodar con drones es genial
hermoso tu puedes
Existe tal afición como la aerofotografía es posible
decir que yo también soy su partidario allí
resultó que mis servicios son excepcionales
en demanda por el ejército Bueno, afortunadamente en
principios Decidimos muchos, muchos
tareas con la ayuda de estos drones vamos a
resolver
cierto conocimiento en este campo I Pero aún
Yo lo tengo, y lo hice un poquito, eso es todo
las cosas en el complejo me trajeron mucho
inteligencia rápida literalmente en el primer
durante la guerra, junté todo lo que tenía
me estaba preparando, entiendo que la guerra puede
empezar
Ahora toda la vida como ejército se basa en
los drones, en primer lugar, son los ojos de la guerra, en segundo lugar -
sigue siendo un componente de choque
en primer lugar, es la detección del enemigo
tienes que ver que pasa en ese
lado con el fin de saber cuáles son realmente
acciones que debemos tomar dónde disparar artillería
cómo colocar sus posiciones de retirada
avance y así sucesivamente
inteligencia decidió de manera realista y
tareas humanitarias es que
por ejemplo, no sabían lo que estaba pasando con
por nuestros refugiados de ese lado, es decir
en realidad había una humanitaria
el corredor a lo largo de este terraplén es diferente
corredor humanitario allá en este puente
en este terraplén
nos enteramos de que hay un problema allí
el agua ha subido y no pueden simplemente
hicieron una transición normal allí
una balsa improvisada en la que se puede
cruzar a una persona mentirosa, por ejemplo
o todos los demás tienen que ir así
agua y luego hubo una temperatura
la temperatura del agua allí está entre 3 y 4,5
Entonces, ¿qué pasa si no todos pueden hacerlo y eso es todo?
debido a esto, estaba seguro, por así decirlo, cierto
tal problema con el condimento, lo haríamos si
Por supuesto, el fabricante está allí a través de la mediación.
La Cruz Roja fue encontrada aquí sin resfriado
un pequeño bote como ese que pesa 70 kg y
solo tiró que podían aunque
para cruzar desde Nosotros de alguna manera tan pequeños
civilizado al menos este proceso
en la medida en que podría ser socializado
todas las situaciones
[música]
también tenemos diferente información sobre
algo destruido en quien, es decir, bien
gente de primaria tal vez no saben
Incluso quiero saber en qué condiciones
su casa
hay diferentes tipos de Drones son complejos en
La gestión es sencilla, es decir, para algunos
drones simples, en principio, en el mío
la persuasión es simplemente cuidadosa
y un operador equilibrado que puede
para resolver ya ciertas tareas a ser
extremadamente útil en la parte delantera
es parte de nuestro trabajo lo que tú
si usa un dron civil, debe
es solo aceptar estar ante ella
listo que te van a fusilar porque
el cilindro A es visible desde el punto de vista
encontrar al operador y estaría lejos de serlo
moscas Es decir, estás obligado todo el tiempo Ot
muerde al enemigo y estos pocos
incluso cientos de metros para
fuiste unos metros más allá y moriste
donde te interesa
atrás
bombardeo de mortero
cannon optim es parte del trabajo
del operador actual, espero que aunque
después de un mes de alguna manera cambia Nosotros
conseguiremos suficientes Drones
estandarte militar
caminos militares Claro, esta es otra historia
puedes volar desde muy lejos
imperceptible para el enemigo excepto para mi
los drones militares todavía están aquí en persona
No he visto mis manos en un mes y medio de guerra
no aguantó
[música]
para mí una victoria significaría
desmilitarización de Rusia
es decir, para que no haya un enemigo real
podemos
será una victoria, es decir, entiendo lo que son
teóricamente podemos lograr eso
incluso salió de Ucrania
pero el sueño de Rusia sobre lo que no permanecerá
nunca seremos destruidos Por lo tanto, creo que
será necesario lograr tal paridad
oportunidades militares Cuándo será
garantizado
[música]
si quieres ayudar a ucraniano
por favor envíe victorias a Ucrania
drones militares o ayuda
dinero a través de fondos de caridad y que
Gloria a Ucrania realmente nos ayudará